I feel like I've had it with people
blatantly treating my husband a certain
way and making him look a certain way in
this clip from Sunday's Keeping Up with
the Kardashians Kim goes to bat for
Kanye following the backlash from his
famous video up they would like me and
Taylor my still has sex why I made that
famous and while Kim doesn't
specifically name names it's pretty
obvious who she's really had it with she
legitimately quote says as soon as I get
on that Grammy red carpet I'm gonna tell
all the press like I was in on it and
she just didn't like the reaction yeah
and you know just another way to play
the victim definitely got her a lot of
attention the first time it always comes
back to the 2009 VMAs I'm really happy
for you I'm let you finish but Beyonce
had one of the best videos of all time I
just don't think that he should be
punished for it still to this day Kim
told GQ earlier this year that Taylor
was made well aware of the famous lyric
even seeing Kanye has video of the
moment he and Taylor spoke Taylor's rep
told et in June Kanye did not call for
approval yeah I'm just like speaking the
truth like he called her spoke to her
she even helped him like rewrite yeah
it's so wild
you